look this is uh john lovitz
oh we met i know him
really when did you meet
oh many times many times you've met her
husband
yeah
oh you probably do a trivia night with a
bazooky cookie together
have you ever been to zara's
what are you laughing at you know
a memory city of atd of me
i've never been no i i've never been i
never i had a bazooky cookie but i never
been to zara's
do you like golf
i do i well i used to but i find that
once you get to the windmill it gets so
tough
it really does yeah it's timing well but
i can't get the cart around the the
one time i was on a date with a a
girlfriend from high school and uh we're
at the windmill and uh
you date high school girls still when i
was in high school okay and we were the
same age like 17 and and
the golf was
uh she wasn't good at she was frustrated
she goes let's go in the windmill and
have sex and we did
you ever been to hawaii
did you have sex in a windmill at a nope
i know totally made that up oh
you wanted good stories
but they have to be true
no you didn't say that yeah
yeah
that's is that how you came up with the
liar character on snl because you don't
talk the truth is i came up there was
another girl a friend of mine i liked
and i and she said i wanted to go out
there she's like no i like guys with a
fat wallet so i said well my dad had 15
oil wells just come in she goes yeah
right
well i am a pathological liar and then i
was in the groundlings theater we had to
do characters it was
and so um
the exercise called panel so there'd be
a host and there'd be and then like a
like a tv show hosting six of us in
chairs and they go you have to come up
with a character in the first two lines
so i said
i did the liar and i go hello my name is
tommy flanagan i'm a member of
pathological liars anonymous
in fact i'm the president of that
organization
and then the audience would ask
questions so someone says
uh how long have you been
how long have you been a liar and i
don't know what you're talking about and
they said you know you said you're a
pathological liar i'm like no
i never said that
so i thought that was funny like i'm
just denying and then robin schiff who
was in the groundlings who's a wrote the
movie romy and michelle and siri great
writer she was in the growlings and she
she i you know came up to me she was
john you set it up perfect
just answering character and i'm like i
did she was yeah and i didn't see it she
was she had to point it out so she was
i'll ask you a question what's your
favorite sport i went
uh
bowling and it just became funny because
you knew he was lying and then i wrote a
monologue of it and did it in the
growlings got on the and we got on the
tonight show and i did it the first time
i did it was on the tonight show it's on
youtube
march 28 1985. oh throw that up happy
anniversary we'll watch it
hello my name is
tommy flanagan and i'm a member of
pathological liars anonymous
in fact i'm uh
i'm the president of that organization
yeah that's who i am
i didn't always lie no i used to tell
the truth but then one day i i told a
lie and i got away with it yeah
told my parents i had a brother that
they'd never met
they got mad at me for not telling them
sooner
and they kicked me out of the house
yeah that's what happened
[Laughter]
so then i drifted for a while until i
landed a job
yeah
as a stock broker
in india
and i was about to make an investment in
a cow
when all of a sudden that a small
chinese man
came up to me and before i knew he was
clipping my nails yeah that's what he
was doing
and i was about to pay him for a job
well done went out of the sky fell a a
herd of
albino chickens
and they swooped down on us and and
gently sucked up all the air
and i blacked out
but when i came to
i was
i was in the middle of the ocean
and a surfboard
surfing
good too
why i was hanging a minimum of five at
all times
and then
that's hysterical
that's on the tonight show
yeah they uh
johnny jim mccauley
you know booked all the comedians like
i'm sure he found you right no
but i tried to get him to to find me and
he hated me and he would never book me
and you know who booked me oh i'm sorry
i know you're bringing up bad bad men
well i didn't know i because i remember
everybody uh not me
well
it was jay leno and
and uh
jerry seinfeld the first time in
roseanne and bill maher all these people
and he came to the groundlings i didn't
even know they were there
and on the sunday i get this message
20 messages on my voicemail machine
which we had then saying congratulations
congratulations from the everybody in
the groundlings but which is
an improv group on melrose like second
city but anyway
did you get to that show on time
yeah
i know but
because there was probably an accident
you knew about
no it's because it counted
so then
i get all these messages i don't know
what they're for
everyone's congratulating me not saying
for what so i called the theater next
day and tom maxwell was the artistic
director from i think north carolina and
big as he goes i go tom what's going on
everyone's congratulating me for what he
goes we're going on the tonight show
this is on a monday i go when he goes i
go who he goes you gonna do your liar
pace and you and tim stack do the truck
man driver and uh don woodard and kate
benton and mindy sterling gonna do the
white man's rap i go when he goes
thursday i go
thursday and we're screaming i couldn't
believe it i didn't even know they were
there
and then on thursday i go and i was
really nervous because when i would do
those first two lines you know a member
of pathological liars anonymous fact i'm
a i'm
i'm the president of that organization
half the time the audience would laugh
right half the time they wouldn't they
didn't get it right right so i go if
they don't get that opening joke the
piece doesn't work so i kept saying tom
what am i going to do what am i going to
do i was so nervous you see this was
this was going to be my second time
on television
ever my first time was on this uh show
the paper chase the second year when i
was 25.
now howie mandel it's three years later
howie mendel's podcast three years later
so
i go out in the set and the growlings is
a 99-seat theater
it's so small like like the audi from
where i'm sitting in this couch to you
is how far away the first person in the
audience is they're like ten feet you
gotta you gotta say how long that is a
lot of people are listening they don't
know three feet but we are about ten
feet i said it's not ten feet we're not
ten feet away we closer kind of yeah we
hurt a lot closer how many feet six well
as a single man you should i know it's
your daughter i was gonna say but i can
hit her in the head with my
private part
anyway
that's how close we are i'm
uncomfortable about six feet
so
so if you you did it in your ass from
here to her ear okay so
not that i would
do you have a big penis oh my god i
don't know six feet in cold water big
i don't know i don't know either so
anyway
so we're on
so and then i go into this theater
the tonight show and it look it's like
380 people it goes straight up in the it
looks like it's gigantic and i said to
the director where do i look because
normally you know in a theater you look
i've never been on on the tonight show
and i see the audience you know i go do
you play the audience it's like like
being in a theater huge theater he was
just look play it straight to camera
let me tell you something you watch
comics on after that a lot of them and
then uh
you know
when jay leno's doing it they didn't
they never looked in the camera they
looked everywhere but in the camera
right
which is so stupid because most of the
audiences kind of stupid is that
watching it
well i don't know what they're telling
them joe coy who used to before he's
huge now but he did it i go joe play to
the camera i go there's millions of
people watching you on that camera at
home there's 380 people there he didn't
look at it once
and i said you idiot
anyway he
i'm telling you they don't they're wrong
because it was a different director you
look into when you go on tv if you're
comedian you get a break you play to the
camera that's where millions of people
are looking if you like look at it for a
second look away you keep breaking your
connection with the audience which is at
home
most of the people in the audience are
watching the monitors
you know what i mean right you're on a
podcast now where you're looking
well i don't where i'm looking at you
oh and the cameras are to the right
genius they should be behind you over
there so i'm looking into the lens we'll
reset the cameras after i'm done
[Music]
you